flexing five and three with a four six
eight the twins beat him up a little bit
here at target field way back in april
built a six nothing lead in a game they
would eventually lose and that'll bring
up left fielder trevor larnak
here's the one-two on the way in a swing
and a miss at an off-speed pitch for
strike three and down goes larnak
strikeout number one for chris flexon
as he takes care of the twins one two
three here in the top of the first
inning we're underway here at t-mobile
we had to the bottom of the first our
home street bank score minnesota nothing
and the mariners coming up pitching
match up tonight one-time mariner
38-year-old veteran lefty jhap in his
15th season going for the twins
j.p crawford ambushing the first pitch
jp live in the yard
oh
jp crawford's fourth
with a bang on the first pitch
j.b crawford with a lead-off home run
here in the bottom of the first inning
giving the mariners a very quick one to
nothing lead and so one-nothing seattle
then bring up jake fraley
and throws him up there
a little bit of a look back toward home
plate maybe directed at the empire came
back from 3-0 to strike him out swinging
and that'll bring up dylan moore
right-handed batting second baseman at a
triple last night with an rbi
runner at second two out the one two
swinging a miss and down he goes good
velocity 93 again a fastball in and the
bases are loaded for left fielder shed
long here's the 01 pitch of the waist
wing to drive into the gap in right
center field this one will get all the
way to the wall murphy will score bowers
running third he scores terrans rowley
third being waved in he's gonna score
heading for third with a dive sliding in
chad long junior is safe at third he
clears the bases with a three-run triple
into the gap in right center field and
the mariners with a four-nothing lead
over minnesota one out four-nothing
mariners and here's fraley here's the
pitch on the way up and in and off the
glove for the catcher rorfett gets
behind home plate here comes longin from
third to score
aaron is now lead
by a score of five to nothing
the wind up and the 3-2 and down he goes
second time fraley has had a 3-2 count
against half second time
and jay has struck him out
so no oh for four
yesterday and marco gonzalez just toyed
with him with breaking balls yesterday
strike him out the first two times
there's a 2-2 to ceno swung on foul tip
murphy holds on her strikeout one down
second strikeout for chris flexing
now tom murphy
he walked and scored back in the four
run second
3-2 swing and a miss baron is five and
the twins nothing and that'll bring up
left fielder trevor larnak
flexon looks in ready
and the right-handers
o2 on the way here she comes and a swing
and a miss and another changeup for
strike three
so that is strike on number three for
chris flexon and the twins have two down
here in the top half of the fourth
one aboard and the battery is designated
hitter nelson cruz and what a
performance right now for chris flexon
arise elite at first base
and he goes three-two pitch swing and a
miss and an off-speed pitch for strike
three flexon striking out nelson cruz
for his fourth strikeout of the ball
game and that's it for minnesota in the
top of the fourth and what a game right
now for chris flexing we head to the
bottom of the fourth braley now fraley's
over two with a couple of punch-outs
here's the stretch
and the two-nothing pitch of jake swung
on little soft fly ball into shallow
right field and that's gonna drop in for
a base hit long rounding third heading
home being waved in by manny's gonna
score down to second goes crawford
jake braley parachutes a base hit and a
run batted in for jake here in the
bottom of the fourth
and it's now the mariner's six and the
twins nothing and now it's kyle seeger's
turn
breaking ball got him needs to be a
throw to first because it is unoccupied
two down and now dylan moore
trailing six nothing here in the 101
popped up
back a second a rise is there on that
perfectly manicured grass he'll make the
catch and all things considered the
twins avoid really a disastrous fourth
giving up just a single run that the
catcher but a broken back ground out to
jp crawford his first time up mariners
with the run and the first in a jp
crawford home run four in the second
highlighted by a three run triple by
shed long he scored on a pass ball
his one-two pitch
swing and a miss struck him out two down
in the sixth time france
doubled the center hit by a pitch for
the 12th time
and grounded out the third two and two
let's see if he can get a hold of one
here
nobody out two on two two pitch
swung on line drive over the shortstop's
head in the left field here comes jp
crawford coming to third he gets the
wave on he'll score easily the throw cut
of it cut off by donaldson and ty france
delivers another run for the mariners
it's 7-0 seattle here in the sixth base
is loaded for the murf
tom murphy
one out base is loaded
on one pitch swung on high fly ball
center field and deep standing in the
yard nick gordon's under it didn't see
it now he makes the catch tagging his
friendly walks home
and tom murphy with the sacrifice fly
makes it eight nothing here in the sixth
inning nice job out of merv
here's bowers
swung on popped up
left field larnick circling in he's got
friends and family in attendance
two-handed catch there for trevor
larnick and the inning mercifully comes
to a close only two runs score here's
luis torrence swing on driven deep to
left there it goes home run luis thorens
into edgars and the mariners have a nine
nothing lead
for terence's third home run of the
season rbi number seven jumped on the
first pitch from grifton jacks
here is first baseman miguel ceneaux and
again the 2-2 to snow and it's strike
three gold he got him looking hey career
high eight strikeouts for chris flexon
and there's two down for the twins here
in the top of the eighth inning and what
a performance by the right-hander chris
flexon on a new work california first
year in the mariners uniform he has been
outstanding strikeout number eight and
county
france is two for three tonight with a
single a double and a run banning in the
look in by jax
he's giving manager rocco baldelli some
innings tonight after half only one four
here's a swing and a drive deep to left
field deep into the night and this one
is gone goodbye baseball into edgar's
cantina
ty france with a home run here in the
bottom of the eighth inning his fourth
home run of the season
holy smokes and the mariners third home
run in the ball game and it's now the
mariners 10
and the twins nothing
last hope tonight for the twins is josh
donaldson best ready looking for that
27th out here's the stretch the one
nothing pitch swinging a line shot the
left field shed long right in his tracks
he makes the catch and the ball game is
over